el beto que turquía levanto la semana
pasada en la cumbre de madrid en contra
de la entrada a la otan de suecia
finlandia podría volver a ponerse en pie
así lo ha explicado el ministro de
asuntos exteriores turco mevlüt
cavusoglu esta misma mañana cuando ha
afirmado que turquía podría vetar de
nuevo la entrada a estos dos países si
éstos no cumplen con los acuerdos
supuestamente firmados en madrid-
turquía sobre todo se refiere a la
extraditación de 73 supuestos
terroristas de estos dos países suecia
de finlandia hacia turquía algo que de
momento no ha ocurrido y parece que no
va a ocurrir ya que primero de todo no
se defienden no se comprometían a
hacerlo en el acuerdo firmado en madrid
y segundo porque la justicia europea
considera que deportar y extraditar a
presuntos terroristas hace turquía es
algo no recomendable por la posibilidad
de que estas personas no reciban un
juicio justo de vuelta a turquía mañana
martes en bruselas suecia en finlandia
aplicarán formalmente para la adhesión
a la otan y a partir de aquí los
parlamentos de todos los países menos
tendrán que ratificar la entrada de
estos dos países si uno lo hace
estancada puede ser vetada y eso es a lo
que amenaza precisamente turquía el
parlamento turco ha dicho al ministro
exteriores turco podría no ratificar la
entrada de se afilan a la otan y por lo
que por lo tanto la entrada de esos dos
países podría retrasarse aún más de lo
que se espera